this morning on a coast to coast
broadcast of the mutual broadcasting
system it is our pleasure to pay a
tribute to a gentleman who's sitting at
our microphones here now in the
department of the interior building i'd
like to repeat again that tribute before
we start this little discussion mr
jackson
we said this morning
one of america's grand old men has a
birthday this week
he will be 98 years old friday think of
that lacking only two years of being a
century old
i think it's safe to say that no one in
the world living today
has looked upon the things this man has
seen
no man will ever see them again for
william henry jackson is part and parcel
of america's old west
it was 75 years ago way back in 1866
that he worked his way west on the
oregon trail as a bull hiker he was the
first man who ever took pictures in the
yellowstone country
with his camera and with his able brush
he has photographed and painted a record
of our early west that would not exist
otherwise
he went as a bull whacker with the
mormons to salt lake he was with a mule
freight outfit that lugged stuff over
the mountains to a little village called
los angeles
he rode heard on mustangs around another
little village called omaha
because this man had the eye of an
artist and the instinct of a historian
we have a better understanding today
of the beginning of our great west
much of the development of the west was
aided by his work
the magnificent and full life you've had
william henry jackson and his thanks and
the nation's best wishes to you on your
98th birthday
that was in the broadcast this morning
and now we're very happy mr jackson that
you're here with us now
and can tell us in your own words some
of these things that i know you would
like to have us know
well on your last trip across the west
did you notice any changes in the
character and the vigor of the grass
from that which you observed in the 70s
well that's been called to my attention
lately by modern pictures that people
have sent me from their conservation
society but there i just called to mind
the great difference of the luscious
grass that we used to camp on which are
now dusty plains
some parts of the middle of western
wyoming
well do you remember how the cowboys
handled their trail herds in the great
cattle drives between texas and montana
i am now engaged in painting a picture
covering that very subject showing the
big
drive of the old longhorn period up
across the autism trail into wyoming
that's as you remember it yeah
i i only crossed the trail i didn't
follow it i see
now just when did sheep begin to compete
seriously with cattle all along the late
80s mothers
and you're a part of all those
differences of opinion that took place
at that i more acquainted i got there
before they
before the cowboy came in even
i liked that think of that period before
the cardboard period the cardboards
began to come in during the seven days
and they had the full spray for the next
10 years
and then they began to compete with the
homesteaders and the uh
and the uh and then the and the cover
and the uh the cowboys well now did you
uh actually see any of these old range
wars that took no i never
the johnson county war as they call it
then wyoming like we're a little bit out
of my territory we were up in the
mountains more my work with the
geological city was almost entirely in
the mountains
and that's what's on the plane
[Music]
where all that stuff all that water had
occurred
you've seen lots of buffalo i expected
oh male and gentleman
would you like to tell us about what
those herds looked like when you oh a
great massive dark brown diamond moving
grazing across the plains when i first
when i first saw a great herd
it was the first year the kansas pacific
ran across the plains
and we ran through them all day long
by the superfly had to stop the train to
get them off the track
they stopped us up several times there
as far as you could see in this now
those flat planes and the extreme
distance you could still see them moving
on
you mean this was just one herd that
took the entire day for the train well
they were all in front of the hood they
let the whole mass of uh uh buffalo one
of the great knights of all same
together nothing different herds but one
great movement covering miles of
territory
would you estimate how many might be in
such a hopefully impossible to guess
some people call it millions but that's
rather exciting
did you see the hunting of the buffalo
oh thousands uh what was the how did
they haunt the buffalo then
how did they hunt the buffalo oh just by
the uh horseback and chasing
brother was running about him the old
union with a spear and born arrow and
our modern people were there
with their guns
i must have landed down several buffalo
using only a uh a revolver
riding up close to them and firing on
their
their flank
uh how about other game
not that the other game oh that is
abundance of course
but game and the trail as we traveled
were sometimes hard to find
game at that time was shy
a large body challenge would become
unnecessary made more noise disturbance
and the game would scatter into the
mountains and hide away
so sometimes we even had to employ
hunters to go out and get the game for
our own
for our own meals well that was good
with all the friends on the trail
uh what would you say was the fertility
of the soil then oh
around through where the strains fell
through the flat belly buttons and the
street water valleys all those western
streams the uh fortuitously very good
indeed
of course that's all proved by the by
the fine crop they raised when they came
into production
well now was there water in the streams
in those days oh yes maybe not much
well they were not considered then there
were dry seasons when the streams are
almost flow drying
but of course at that time early day
there's no irrigation except in a very
small way
so that they can find themselves to
immediate vicinity of the water but
there was no they didn't understand
about rainfall at all
they had upon irrigation but in a
limited way
now what did people do for amusement in
those days what were their amusements oh
i don't know there's no amusement that's
renewed today
so i went to bed early in california i
see
what what about the social life oh the
exclusive educational
getting more people for a dance like the
old-fashioned band and all the
restaurant had their dancing night this
is the great amusement they might say of
all gathering the people all together
for a dance
and the old time square dances almost
universally at that time
all this could find a fiddler
or somebody who could play music of some
kind
well uh
a man who might have been out there at
that time
making a living on that land
uh what did how did he make his money
how much money was needed or did he just
well they're making they mostly
concerned making a living
not for selling so much that came in
mostly with the cattle business later
and also when the
overland stage lines are running by
raising hay and touching for the service
of the pony express and the overland
stage and things of that kind
those places all had to be stuck to hay
they lived upon that almost entirely
and of course that's one of the pushed
products you might say was that of
course in the moments within that they
began it went to the wheat cup
on the first year of their entrance into
salt lake valley they had a wheat crop
growing at once
by sowing their wheat and corn i should
say besides the wheat
let's see
what do you recall mr jackson is in your
opinion the most
interesting thing that happened to you
in your entire experience in the west
you have any one thing that you think
would be
pretty hard to segregate uh one
one item because my uh
experience has been so
would you want a glass of answer why did
you try it in general
that's right
but i've always called the most
interesting period of my life the 10
years i spent in the west with the
hayden survey
as always in my most interesting period
new things of its own new places to
photograph questions to bring to the
attention of the world to make the
yellow
region known
to make the mountain the holy cross
known to the peak to make known to
people they just fell into the south
all very interested in
thinking themselves but no one startling
dramatic
single incidents you might say
they're standout problems more or less
you have probably been the first man to
have looked upon or the first white man
at any rate to have looked upon many of
those natural wonders out there have you
not been well in a way not the first to
look upon them so much as the
professionals perpetuate them in
pictures
pretty hard to say in this america virus
where a man has not been that's true but
we're among the
first people to follow the
tales of those unnamed people trappers
and people of that kind who may have
seen these things but we were the place
to make them publicly known well what
were some of those things that you made
known for the first time to the rest of
the country yellowstone holy cross the
cliff building the main and rocky
mountain chain of peace free miles peak
and all the big uh the teton mountains
all are prominent features today in the
scenic wonders of the west
i have seen some of those pictures
you've made mr jackson made on the tops
of mountains
where you knew that it must have been
tremendously difficult just to get to
the point and carry that was the main
part of my experience with the hayden
survey was carrying that cumbersome very
weighty pull together
stops a high peak the apparatus for
making pictures here right amounted for
fully 100 pounds of weight you had to
carry out of course i had to have
assistance there's generally three of us
we carry our pack animals up them off as
far as recording then we distribute
their loads to our own soldiers to our
own shoulders and carry the tops of the
peak
i killed put nearly all of the high
peaks of colorado in that way
from the
town including fremont now the high
peaks of colorado
and cleared up my water and all their
protests and the cameras and everything
i can for making the pictures sometimes
i had to spend nearly all day on top to
get pictures between intervention storms
that come over the peak
and now these days we think it's quite
an achievement if a man goes up there
carrying a mini cam with him
would you tell us something about the
way you had to make pictures in those
days
some of the way you had to make pictures
how you made the exposure
briefly our old process before 1880
when the dragon came into being
was what he called a wet clothing
process
we carried out clean glass plates whole
other
whole lot of chemicals collodians and
developers and iron solutions and acid
solution and everything again filters
and trays and bottles and everything of
that kind besides the portable dark room
to work in
we had to go into that little tent take
one of those green glass plates throw it
with a collodion emboss it in a silver
bath of nitrate of celery
and while still wet
put in the plate hole and exposed in the
usual way
then it had to be developed immediately
after it were wet and the plate dried as
well as it could
store in a glued box to protect it in
that condition and the camp had to be
clothed with a protective varnish and
packed away
i have tried
i want to keep by coaching my assistants
see how quickly we can make a picture
from the driving at the point where i
wanted us to maintain we had to unpack
the new record
and distribute the apparatus set up the
tent get the camera ready and then i go
into that little tent and cook my plate
and prepare it for exposure
and after development it is that factory
they have safe set and then put on the
mule again under such conditions with
two assistants working with me i've been
i've taken 30 minutes to make a picture
but ordinal takes more time than that
and what's located why of course you can
make a number of pictures with a
compatible short time
exposure down the plate that time
average all the way from
sometimes even to one second 5 10 15 or
20 seconds for an exposure
extreme it after a minute instead of
second
i expect in those days out there you've
photographed many people have you not to
been a part of our west our early
history we didn't forget many people
many groups we're rather limited in that
account we're out there for just about
so much work we couldn't carry only the
only six quantity of gas but that is
heavy
we generally had as i might say for a
season to work with 400 years late
and we were sent upon the scenery we
didn't care about our own feathers
didn't care about what they did
themselves individually we were
interested in what they saw new places
things of that kind and towards the end
of the season if uh
if
there are still things to be pulled out
that had not been
taken well we'd wash off from the old
group picture and use them for scenery
of course the scenery remained but those
people have passed
my request in some cases
uh you you must have known and been
acquainted at any rate with a lot of
those
characters of the early west we're not
they were not promised no david didn't
think much of them and there's all just
one of us at the same time
uh of course i missed personally all the
prominent people at least now they're
well-known people of that period
you'd like to mention some of those
people of that day
would you like to mention some of those
people of that day who
played a part in making the way oh of
course there's first of all our old
geological survey people besides hayden
there's power and there's kane and
there's wheeler and all the people
associated with it and of course nearly
these men of the old well-known scout
that figured largely in the
undercover period of the west like bill
hickman and cody and
people and the people in syria and
gendry who'd like that medicine and some
other matters and
some of those people who named i don't
fall just now
but they're all circling more or less
during that late 1670 period
jackson i i just wouldn't know the
questions to ask you
to bring out the things that i
know you'd like to say
when you just like to go ahead and just
talk now and and tell us all
of the things that you remember and what
you think of their importance
both of yesterday and as they might be
in relation to things today
well you've already had a niggling i
have an outline of my story
was mostly concerned the survey period
of the 1670s
i began photography way back when i was
15 years old
way back from when i was 17 or 18 years
old
and
pursuing that business was very
discovered it finally took me up into
vermont before the civil war
there i got interested in the civil war
proceedings of course and went into a
vermont regiment
i served down in the army of the potomac
coming back from that end of vermont i
uh
pulled up stakes in vermont on a kind of
a
disruptive live affair
as they called it went west
that agent 66 is already mentioned
that quote took me to california and
then back
returning from california behind the
band of uh about 150 mustang opponents
driving at 2000 miles across the country
from
from los angeles to uh up through salt
lake back to omaha
there i thought i'd had enough of that
kind of wandering and went into
photographic business
set up a gallery of my own and dick van
worked on the union pacific road and
building western florida up that road
from one end to the other
that brought me in contact with dr
hayden who was then running a survey of
the western territory
he liked my work so well and thought it
should be an important part of his own
work and he introduced me to join the
survey
i gave up on dennis nomar
as a local photographer and for the next
nine years included where i worked for
the survey
there was a set that i already mentioned
to cover the most eventful period of my
life really
and from that time i when i quit the
survey i left boston went to denver and
set up a business for myself
my work from that time began with the
rapid development of the western railway
system
watching out everywhere all over the
west colorado especially with the rig
and the santa fe and the southern
pacific
all those old they punished me with
private cars crews and engine and all
that and during the next 15 or 20 years
my work has almost entirely been
following up the development of the
western railroad
during that period of course i made very
many pictures for exhibitions
particularly for the colombian
expedition in trouble 93
after that i prepared a series of
pictures over the bottom ohio road that
i made the previous year
the uh publicity
agency completion network he conceived
the idea of taking me around the world
with the transportation commission
so-called
so in the latter part of 94
with a party of five we started abroad
and spent the next 18 months going all
over eastern eastern continent
from all the way from england with the
far
point of the far east down to australia
and the philippines and the
and the japan and finally the veteran
on the pacific and returned from there
overland perspective in the winter time
making a 3000 mile
trip over the snowy roads of eastern
siberia
protecting all the way those pictures by
the way being published and
harper's weekly during that period
pretty weekly and all the issues of that
paper during the latter by the night of
five nights at six
that caused one of my longest trips to
that kind because they took the whole
route from the last truck to moscow and
covering that uh except in that year
return snap to new york where we came
back in the depression period of the
night
late 90s and that kind of threw me out
of this
until finally i joined in as a
california concern and went to detroit
in 98 and for the next 25 years and
engaged in color printing business
converting these photographs loudly into
color views postcards largely we turned
out millions and millions of postcards
using all my own
negated me during the previous 40 odd
years i understand that you're the
father of the postcard well that is the
power that's the assumption i think
i when i was in the army i sent home in
every letter a little picture the side
of an envelope that i've drawn out or a
whole lot of them and when i got it they
came home my people i gathered them up
to show again being a picture similar to
the postcard to the card picture
it might have been assumed
that the first to the postcard although
not milled assets
although it's amazing
in an envelope
i mean a great minute the writer and the
post here in new york presumed that to
be uh
the artisan but i couldn't say it
i don't think you're logical in origin
i think that's as logical an origin as
anyone else yes but i don't know where
the picture being used for that purpose
before that time the little picture part
you made made different sizes and so but
not the size of a downrow as a picture
card as we know them today
you've been responsible for a great many
million people i expect then saying
uh wish you were here
sending the picture where they were
uh in connection with your trip around
the world mr jackson since your eye had
been
[Music]
for natural beauty
primarily
and you'd had the opportunity of seeing
a
great deal of our country and then the
opportunity to see
the beautiful nature spots of other
countries
what in your honest opinion is is the
comparison there
is america a beautiful country
well the aesthetic part of america is
pretty well done
[Music]
photographers now more intense upon
[Music]
hollywood and their latest if they are
on the scene
[Music]
how would you say that our american
scenery compares to the scenery of other
nations oh they're little spots of it
that are equal to
and the attractive is anything you have
abroad
they take down take their jacks in the
whole country and take our yellowstone
which is unique they got grand canyon
they call us
things that cannot be paralleled
anywhere else
and i think that we have here greater
detection that way
of course that they have abroad of
course we haven't the ground out or
having tamales
and the great many things we haven't but
to have things equally
attractive in a way i think
people talk about the centenary of my
work in the united states
i'm very happy to have it linked up here
with a geological survey
and the connection with photography
which my light has been widely
identified
i've covered a little more than 80 years
of active service and photography
coming into it on the very heels of the
old primitive crazy process and
following through all its courses up to
the present time mostly in connection
with public surveys in the west
my early page across there was covered
by skechers
then i took up the work of the
geological survey in 1870
and followed through all that decade of
the seven days
and that brings me back here again after
these 75-hour years to
so join again with the old the
explorers of today exported a club in a
geological survey in various allied
organizations of that kind
my life had been devoted to picturizing
the weather
when i gave up photography
and with the old protesters i took the
pencil in the paintbrush
and it
preserved many we went into the old
trail in that way
yes go right ahead mr jackson
well for the last 15 years that i
retired connective business i've been
more active than ever in carrying on the
story of the old west that's been
largely in connection with the work of
the dealer of the oregon trail
association covering my original route
across the continent as well as
picturizing it now for future records of
the old of the old west
because i bring to it not only my
original work in sketch into it but the
memory of all those things which are
still fresh in mind and they were to
carry on the old story by picture and
other means of that kind
it's been a great pleasure to meet the
boys of the geological survey here i
come here for nearly annually although
my home is now in new york but i keep a
lot of the old story and from here i go
west every year
still following the old trails from the
little river to the coast as they call
it by
foot and airplane and motorcycle and
every imaginable way took them thing out
i've covered i think for expert nearly
every way of traveling across the
continent
well i want to thank you very very much
mr jackson for coming up here and giving
us this opportunity of of having your
voice put in this transcription so we
may know these things yeah thank you
very much
this electrical transcription is an
interview with william henry jackson
made on the eve of his 98th birthday
and recorded in the radio studios of the
department of the interior
thursday april 3
1941
mr jackson was interviewed by shannon
allen
director of the radio section of the
department of interior
you